we've been doing some interesting things
in the last few videos we let go of our
newtonian assumptions that the passage
of time is the same in all inertial
frame of reference the time is absolute
that one second in my frame of reference
is the same as one second passing in
your frame of reference we even let go
of the idea that space is absolute that
one meter in a certain direction in my
frame of reference is going to be the
same as one meter in your frame of
reference if we're moving at relative
velocities with respect to each other
and what that allowed us to do it
allowed us to reconcile what is actually
observed in the universe and that's the
idea that the speed of light is an
absolute that regardless of what
inertial frame of reference we're in
regardless of the speed of the source of
the light that we will always measure
light traveling at three times or
roughly three times ten to the eighth
meters per second and when we let go of
our assumptions about absolute time in
absolute space
and we did assume absolute velocity for
light it gave us a very interesting
diagram because it took our what took
our x-prime axis from being on top of
the x-axis and put it at an angle
relative to the x-axis
now one question that you might have is
well what is this angle the way i've
drawn it it looks like the angle between
x prime and x is the same as the angle
between t prime and t or as we did in
the last videos we turned our units in
time or the units along this this axis
the c t axis instead of saying seconds
we're now going to measure it in meters
and once again watch the last video if
you five if you if you're having a an
issue with that but it looks like this
angle and this angle is the same what i
want to do in this video is feel good
about the fact that they really are the
same
so one of the convenient things when a
couple of videos ago we went through
this thought experiment of in my
friend's frame of reference her emitting
a photon of light and bouncing off of
the spaceship that's three times ten to
the eight meters in front of her and
then coming back to her is we assumed
that as we mark off the meters and as we
mark off the seconds that the the
distance from the origin for three times
ten to the eighth meters is the same as
the distance from the origin is one
second and now it makes even more sense
because now we call this three times ten
to the eighth meters and this times
three times ten to the eight meters as
well and so the speed when we when we
depict the path of light of a photon in
either of these space time diagrams it's
always going to be at a either a
positive 45 degree angle or a negative
45 degree angle depending on the
direction that the light is traveling in
fact that was what we used to establish
that this x prime axis is going to be is
not going to sit on top of the x-axis
it's going to be at an angle but now
let's actually think about that angle
so if we
if we say that this angle right over
here is
alpha
and if we were to continue this 45
degree line that we had to remember any
path of a photon is going to be at a 45
degree angle so let me continue that
so this is going to look like that and
then we could go back and continue it
right like that well we know that this
is going to be
45 degrees
45 degrees right over there this is
going to be
whoops this is going to be 45 degrees
right over there and we know
we know that this green triangle that
i'm
that green isn't different enough let me
get a better color
this move no that's still green
we know that this
this purplish triangle that i'm setting
up right here this is an isosceles
triangle how do i know that this is an
isosceles triangle well this hash mark
right over here on the c t prime axis
that is 3 times 10 to the 8th meters and
this hash mark on the x prime axis is
also 3 times 10 to the 8 meters and so
this side is equal to that side and so
we know that the base angles of an
isosceles triangle are going to be
congruent so this angle is going to be
congruent to that angle well if those
two angles are congruent then this angle
is going to be congruent to that angle
because they are supplementary to those
two base angles and so notice if we look
at
if we look at this triangle let me do
this in a new color
if we look at
this triangle right over here and
compare it to this triangle right over
here notice they both have a 45 degree
angle they both have this blue angle
which is congruent so the third angle
has to be congruent they always have to
add up to 180 degrees if you have two
angles of two different triangles are
the same then the third angle has to be
the same
and so if this is alpha actually i'll do
let's see i've already used i'll do four
four arcs there if that angle is alpha
then this angle is going to be alpha as
well and so this is really interesting
it's a beautiful kind of symmetry and it
really comes out of the fact that the
speed of light should always be measured
at roughly 3 times 10 to the 8 meters
per second in any inertial frame of
reference notice if we go back to my
frame of reference that photon that i
emit from my my flashlight
it will look like this
it will look like this its path in this
minkowski spacetime from my point of
view will look like that and notice from
from my friend's point of view the one
that's traveling on a ship
for every
for every amount let's say let's pick up
a certain point in space time right over
there
well her x time coordinate is going to
be
right over there and her
c t prime coordinate is going to be
right over there so that makes sense in
one in one i guess we could say light
meter the thing travels a meter so it is
still traveling at the speed of light
from her point of view even though she
is moving at half the speed of light
relative to me and you could think about
what would happen if she was moving even
faster someone moving even faster their
ct prime axis would be at an even at an
even more severe angle so it would be
it might look something like that and
then what would their x prime angle look
like well then their x prime angle is
going to be symmetric around that line
that shows that shows the path of light
so it would look like this so this is
someone
let's say who's moving even faster
relative to me let's call that ct prime
prime and this would be their x prime
prime and so you can imagine you get
close as that as that second frame of
reference gets closer and closer to the
speed of light from my frame of
reference their coordinate axes are just
going to get more and more scrunched up
around around this 45 degree angle so
that's really neat
now another thing i want to think about
and i'll i won't draw it in this video
just because i think i've given you
enough to
to digest is
there's a symmetry here if my friend is
moving at half a speed of light it is
moving at half the speed of light in the
positive x direction according to me
then from her point of view i'm moving
at half the speed of light in the
negative x prime direction so we should
think about well what would if i were to
if we were to look at this right over
here what would what would my frame of
reference look like if i were to project
it on top of that